determine the number of solutions for
each of these equations and they give us
three equations right over here and
before I deal with these equations in
particular let's just remind ourselves
about when we might have one or infinite
or no Solutions you're going to have one
solution if you can by solving the
equation come up with something like X
is equal to some number let's say x is
equal to if I want to say in the
abstract X is equal to a or if we
actually were to solve it we get
something like x equals 5 or 10 or
negative pi whatever it might be but if
you could actually solve for a specific
X then you have one solution so this is
one solution
just like that now if you go and you try
to manipulate these equations in
completely legitimate ways but you end
up with something crazy like three
equals five then you have no Solutions
no Solutions and if you just think about
it reasonably all of these equations are
are about finding and F finding an X
that satisfies this and if you were to
just keep simplifying it and you were to
get something like three equals five and
you were to ask yourself the question is
there any X that can somehow magically
make three equal five no no X can
magically make three equal five so
there's no way that you can make this
thing be actually true no matter which X
you pick so if you get something very
strange like this this means there's no
solution on the other hand if you get
something like 5 equals five and I'm
just overusing the number five it didn't
have to be the number five it could be
seven or ten or or 113 whatever and like
let me just not use five just to make
sure that you don't think it's only for
five if I just get something that
something is equal to itself which is
just going to be true no matter what x
you pick any X you pick this would be
true for well then you have an infinite
infinite solutions
so with that is a little bit of a primer
let's try to tackle these three
equations
so over here let's see maybe we could
subtract if we want to get rid of this 2
here on the left hand side we could
subtract 2 from both sides if we
subtract 2 from both sides we are going
to be left with on the left hand side
we're going to be left with negative 7x
and on the right hand side you're going
to be left with 2x this is going to
cancel minus 9x 2x minus 9x if we
simplify that that's negative 7x you get
Negative 7x is equal to negative 7x and
you probably see where this is going
this is already true for any x that you
pick negative 7 times that X is going to
be equal to negative 7 times that X so
we already are going into this scenario
but you're like hey so I don't see 13
equals 13 well what if you did something
like U divide both sides by negative 7.
negative seven at this point what I'm
doing is kind of unnecessary you already
understand that negative seven times
some number is always going to be
negative seven times that number but if
we were to do this we would get X is
equal to X and then we could subtract X
from both sides and then you would get 0
equals zero which is true for all for
any x that you pick zero is always going
to be equal to zero so any of these
statements are going to be true for any
X you pick so this for this equation
right over here we have an infinite
number of infinite number of solutions
let's think about this one right over
here in the middle
so once again well let's try to Let's
I'll do a little bit different I'll add
this 2X and this and this negative 9x
right over there so we will get Negative
7x plus 3 is equal to is equal to
negative 7x so 2x plus 9x is negative 7x
plus 2
plus 2. well let's add actually that
green color
let's do that in that green color plus 2
that's this 2. now let's add 7x to both
sides well if you add 7x to the left
hand side you're just going to be left
with the 3 there and if you add 7x to
the right hand side this is going to go
away and you're just going to be left
with the 2 there so all I did is I added
7x I added 7x to both sides of that
equation and now we got something
nonsensical I don't care what x you pick
how magical that X might be there's no
way that that X is going to make 3 equal
to 2. so in this scenario right over
here we have no
no Solutions there's no X in the
universe that can satisfy this equation
now let's try this third scenario
so once again let's maybe we'll subtract
3 from both sides just to see get rid of
this constant term so we're going to get
Negative 7x on the left hand side on the
right hand side we're going to have 2X
minus 1.
2x minus 1. and now we can subtract 2x
from both sides
to subtract 2x from both sides you're
going to get so subtracting 2X
you're going to get Negative 9x is equal
to negative 1. now you can divide both
sides by negative 9.
and you are left with X is equal to 1 9.
so we're in this scenario right over
here we very explicitly were able to
find an x x equals 1 9 that satisfies
this equation so this right over here
has exactly one
solution